[Music]
seems like it seems like your characters
make kind of an odd combination I won't
have put them together after seeing
Avengers what kind of dynamics do they
bring to each other it's a working
relationship I mean we they're both
agents of shield highly skilled we've
you know I think when you find books of
our characters we've both been working
together for a couple of years and so
they're kind of a shorthand between them
the fighting styles the the way they
communicate is just you know kind of old
hat and through a series of events
they're sort of brought together in a
kind of unlikely unexpected friendship I
think and kind of help each other to
break down some of those barriers they
both put up you know those were just
behind the scenes but we were just bored
one day we thought let's send the press
for a loop yeah you know we can't say
anything run or lock and key
sure well I think it's hard for cap to
understand what's right and wrong I
think in the first couple films sorry
the first couple films it's pretty clear
to know what's good what's bad we can
all agree Nazis are bad I think in the
modern day it's a little bit more
difficult to understand what the right
thing to do is caps only desire is to
serve and to do the best you can but the
problem is with today's technology and
access it's it's it's a little bit more
of a compromise as to where the line is
drawn as to what's needed to preserve
security direct is a nine of Garlits
always in superhero shape don't let her
tell you anything otherwise that black
widow suit slips on and off pretty easy